we next have amish tell us about causal
matrix completion
hi everyone thank you for
inviting me raghu and vanessa it's a
pleasure to be here so this is joint
work with um munzer daley devraksha who
is sitting here and denis shen who is a
long-time collaborator i think isa
berkeley is a postdoc with uh ben you
and pandey and joss though he's not here
but uh there's a joint work with the
three of them
so when we think of matrix completion we
normally think of recommendation systems
especially like the netflix problem
right so rows of different users columns
are different movies and there's a
rating given to a particular user item
combination but most things are missing
because you don't get to observe most
people don't watch most movies unless
you're maybe a grad student like myself
i've seen a lot of movies uh
um
okay so the goal of matrix completion is
can you recover missing entries of a
matrix right that's what we think about
this netflix problem
but one thing i hope to leave you with
by the end of this talk is that matrix
completion is a lot more than just
netflix okay
the recommendation systems are part and
parcel of everyday life so rosa uses
columns items we have other things as
well for example in econometrics we
are very important concept to stagger
adoption say with medicare where at a
certain age you get medicare say at age
65 before which you don't right so you
can think of this as people who did not
get medicare so at some point you're
observing their outcomes under no
medicare at some point they hit 65 then
the outcomes are missing right so you
have this kind of staircase style
pattern
or for example for mars and ml you can
think of say contextual bandits here
rows would be different states columns
would be different actions say in the
finite state action case and each entry
here would be the reward for a given
state in action
and so what's the goal across many of
these different applications you can
think of it as imputing missing entries
and denoising observed entries
right and the challenge when we try to
think of all these problems collectively
through matrix completion
is that these different kinds of
applications induce very different
sparsely patterns
let's say the challenge of thinking
about this in a through matrix
completion
so what's the setup for matrix
completion you have some matrix m
uh that's you're called we call those
our expected outcomes then your the if
you observe it it's observed with some
sort of noise so y's i i j is going to
be equal to m i j plus epsilon i j
that's when i j is noise
and there's some binary mask matrix a
okay if a i j is equal to one then you
observe y i j and if a i j is equal to
zero then it's not observed it's missing
question mark
and so given y tilde and a
your the goal is to produce an m hat
such that m hat is close to m and
there's many different ways we can
define closeness one the probably the
most uh standard is the frobenius norm
which is the average across all entries
but there's more uh
stronger notions are normal for example
the infinity node which is the recovery
of any particular entry
so that's the setup for matrix
completion now what's the problem why
can't we
apply matrix completion as it stands to
those all the different applications we
talked about the problem is there's no
one unified approach that works across
many different sparsely patterns
so here i'm taking a quote from maya and
chen who at carnegie mellon they wrote a
really nice paper two years ago
on trying to come up with the more
general
pattern of missingness that they allow
for in matrix completion and here's a
quote from the end of their talk
uh sorry at the end of their paper they
say in terms of theoretical analysis
we've not addressed the full generality
of mnr data and matrix completion where
mnr means missing not at random
they say their theory breaks down when
the probability of observation is
exactly zero for example they would not
be able to handle a case where
vegetarian will never go to a steakhouse
they say
we still assume that each entry is
revealed independent of other entries so
examples will not be able to handle the
case where if your data is missing at
time t it's also missing at time t plus
one which is true for example in the
staggered adoption case
and they say these are just two open
problems amongst many for robustly
handling mdr data guarantees so another
problem that might show up for example
is in the contextual bandits the state
actions which are visited either missing
this pattern is going to be confounded i
correlated with the expected reward
right for any given uh contextual
bandwidth mechanism right
and these kinds of assumptions are
similar to what are made by for example
bhattacharya and tattoody chatterjee who
at stanford and by yandi yang di ding
woo nadel who are at cornell
right further most of the results exist
in the matrix completion literature are
generally for recovering average over
the entire matrix in the frabenius gnome
but for many of these settings what
you'd like ideally is recovery for every
particular entry that's the strongest
notion
okay so what is the talking to be about
i'm going to provide you one way of
thinking about this problem that works
both empirically and theoretically
across a wide variety of applications
the way i'm going to break up this talk
is first i'm going to try to motivate
why we should think about missingness
through an empirical example
second i'm going to provide you an
algorithm that we propose called
synthetic nearest neighbors
i'll talk about what it is and then
lastly i'll end with the theoretical
guarantees of synthetic nearest
neighbors
so firstly i'm trying to make a fuss
about the missingness model does it even
matter let's say we just use black box
matrix completion algorithms that exist
if we just applied them to different
sparsely patterns how do they do
so here's a simple um simulation to show
you some of the results so you say i
give you a matrix m just 80 by 80. it's
rank is five
and a binary matrix a
okay
so if aij is equal to one then i said
it's observed otherwise it's not
observed there's no noise in the
simulation okay so the standard model of
missingness is called missing completely
a random or m car
here a i j is equal to one with
probability p
and it's independent of everything else
in the system so for each entry matrix
you flip a coin with its heads with
probability you observe it otherwise you
don't observe it okay and this is the
standard model of missingness that's
been set in literature by a variety of
people started by
candice and rick and candace and tao in
2009 and a variety of other people have
studied it's become a really its own
literature within
statistics in ml and doubly
the more recent model of missingness
that people have started studying is
called at least what we call
limited missing not at random called
lmnar for short
the difference is now that aij is going
to be equal to one with probably pij
right so the intensity with which you
flip that coin is going to change entry
by entry
okay so it's more flexible
and this is what i call the state layout
model of missingness that was one study
by mayan chen my bodhicharyan chatterjee
yang and all
right
the third model of missing this i'm
going to talk through is called missing
not at random
here the probability of observing the
entry can be exactly zero
okay the observing one entry can affect
your probability observing another entry
and m can be correlated with a
okay and this is what i believe my
engine called open problem in their 2019
paper
so let's see so here's a simple
simulation that we all did so in light
blue here is the true distribution of m
okay the ratings are from one to five
this is the true distribution of those
ratings in light blue
in dark blue is what you observe
through the m car samples
as you'd expect the m car samples and
the two distribution look like each
other up to normalization right because
we picked them out at random
the goal of this simulation is that
given the dark blue can you recover the
light blue distribution
the first method i'm going to show you
is called universal singular value
thresholding this is a very very popular
method by a star of strategy that came
out in 2014 i'll be the most popular
spectral filtering method
and to surprise it actually already
stopped working well
even though it's designed for the
setting here and dark blue is what was
recovered by
universal single value thresholding it
seems to just recover the mean
which is quite surprising to us
the second method we tried and this is
really we tried a variety of different
methods
such as soft compute
nuclear normalization etc over all the
different tests we did soft compute is
what tended to work best
and it's by hasty at all
and here it works beautifully right the
dark blue that's recovered completely
covers the light blue as you would hope
so at least it's covering in a
distributional sense
the third method we tried is our own
method called synthetic neurostables
which will explain the algorithm in a
few slides
and it's also working really well right
the dark blue is completely covering the
light blue at least empirically
the second
simulation we tried is now with lmr data
okay so now you can see that the limited
missing order random data and dark blue
is not a good proxy for light blue right
so this bias in the way things are
missing or not missing okay we tried
again universal single very thresholding
it performs even more poorly it seems to
just predict the mean again
and we tried alternating sorry we tried
uh soft compute
and it's working decently but not nearly
as well as it was with m car data right
there's a slight bias you can see a
little bit of the light blue showing up
but it's working decently
and we tried synthetic nearest neighbors
again the dark blue is completely
covering the light blue as you would
hope
we did this process again with missing
not had random data we broke the key
assumptions required for the current
state-of-the-art literature to work
and so you can see now it's like this
blocks tribal structure
and usvt still doesn't work
but to our surprise soft compute
completely stops working
right from that lmnr setting to the end
or setting just switching those killing
those few assumptions it just seems to
just predict one
for some strange reason
that's what you see is that these
methods tend to be very very sensitive
to the missingness pattern and that's
why this is to me a problem of causal
inference because causing things
carefully about messing with
and i weren't sure if it didn't work but
synthetic nearest neighbor still
obviously is uh is uh recovering the the
distribution really well given all three
different missingness patterns
the light blue area looks very different
here
and from the top one here yeah let's
just look at the scale
this is 140 the 1600 it just seems
pretty fun
500 oh oh the scale is different because
of the prediction the prediction is
rather poor
and so this is should give you pause
because m data is something that's
present everywhere recommendation
systems are
present everywhere with movies product
news articles probably most importantly
but even with clinical trials where your
data where you drop out your data you
can think of that as a matrix completion
problem or say the u.s census where more
than 40 of the data for certain
important columns is missing that's we
need to think very carefully about why
your data is missing and how to recover
matrices with such missingness patterns
so now let me give you the synthetic
nearest neighbor algorithm
it's really a mixture of two ideas one
is nearest neighbors so nearest neighbor
is a really simple beautiful method
let's say i want to recover in this
first row the fourth entry here what do
you do if i had if i was looking for one
nearest neighbor i look at what other
row looks like my row
okay there's the second row seems to be
a pretty good proxy there are two
entries here that look quite like it so
maybe i'll use that as my my nearest
neighbor
okay and what was the entry here that
was observed four okay great i'm gonna
call this four
and there's many different
generalizations of this idea what does
it mean to be close
how many nearest neighbors should you
take to take an average there's a bias
variance rate of that happens and
there's a whole literature to it which
is worth studying
and it's also called collaborative
filtering
another method that we build on is
called synthetic controls which comes
from econometrics and it was developed
by uber badi and his co-authors in 2003
and for the analyzed by a variety of
people
and the economical example they give is
asking the question of what if
california never passed proposition 99
which are the tax that was put into
place to reduce the amount of cigarette
sales so there's attack or tax on
tobacco
so this is what they do they say okay at
some point in 1990 california instituted
this tax all the other countries other
states sorry did not institute this tax
so we do is we're going to look at the
pre-intervention outcomes of california
that is the per capita cigarette sales
let's look at the pre-intervention
outcomes of all the other states let's
try to write the pre-dimension outcomes
of california as some linear combination
of the other states the way you do this
linear combination the way you
regularize your fit depends on the
application a body and its co-authors
propose convex regression so s is taken
to be the simplex so there's a variety
of other things you could do
so you take those
weights and you apply that to x2 to get
your expected outcomes in the
post-invention period
so that's synthetic controls in a
nutshell and it's become an extremely
popular method of to do counterfactuals
in the econometrics world
and synthetic nearest neighbors is
really a combination of these two ideas
so synthetic controls and their sabers i
kind of like to think of it as academic
sudoku and we'll see what i mean by that
let's say there's some entry i j that
i'd like to predict
the first step is you find
this
matrix x that's fully filled such
there's a couple of properties first
that the corresponding elements of it in
row i are completely filled so it's
given by ac it's going to have
anchor columns and the corresponding
elements of it in column j are filled
it's called ar
now if you just look at the question
mark ac ar and x that looks a lot like
the synthetic controls problem
that's what we're going to exploit
so now what you do is you actually break
up x into k different sub matrices how
exactly do that i'll talk about that in
a second
which each of these matrices you learn a
model between y one and say x one the
way we propose doing that is by
principle component regression we first
do pca on x1 to find a low-rank
approximation
and then apply that to your x-tilde one
the beta hat that you learn to get your
first estimate you repeat this process
over the k different sub-matrices you
create take the average and that's your
estimate of m had i j that's exactly the
algorithm used to the simulations i just
showed you
why pcr how to
pick a k we'll talk about that in a
second
any questions about the
simple three step algorithm
yeah what's the difference between x1
and x1
so x i'm going to let's say
k is equal to 2 in this sense i'm going
to take x i'm going to break it under
two sub matrices
so i'm just going to partition it by the
the columns i'm going to break up the
first half second half i'm going to
learn a second separate linear model for
each of those two halves
okay it's a choice of partition
uh no a certain assumption is required
for each partition and i'll talk about
that in a second okay
okay
so now why does synthetic nearest
neighbor work simple three-step
algorithm
so here are some of the assumptions that
we require for this algorithm to work
before i tell you the theoretical
results
so in general you need structure on this
matrix to be built in for anything
the most canonical structure you place
is that it's low rank
okay that is there's a low dimensional
latent factor for like low left single
vectors and right single vectors that
explain your data so r here which is the
which is the dimension of u and v
is a lot smaller than m and n
this is called the rank of the matrix
that's the first assumption you require
now the question is what kind of
missingness do we allow for
so given the low rank assumption you can
write your outcomes y i j as some inner
product of u and v that's your lower
dimensional factors plus epsilon i j
that's the noise
what you allow for is this kind of
graphical model that is the missingness
pattern that's determined by a i think
those are interventions
that is
does not epsilon which is the noise has
no direct error to it so latent factors
u and b they can point to a and y in
that sense they correlated
but the epsilon cannot have a direct
arrow to the missingness so your
missingness can only be a function of
the expected rating the expected outcome
versus the noisy outcome
that's the key kind of externality will
offer
and given this the structural assumption
of y ig equals to the inner product of u
and v plus epsilon and this exergenity
what that leads to is that your outcomes
your y and you're missing this pattern a
are independent conditional and u and b
so we call this lecture and latent
factors a similar idea has been studied
for example in
calais at all in 18 atheism 21 and
us as well
so given this kind of assumption
i know that we allow for example the
probability of observing the entry to be
exactly zero
we allow correlation between which
entries you observe in which you don't
observe
and m which is given by the latent
factors your expected outcomes can be
arbitrarily correlated with a
any questions
okay so this is the missingness pattern
that we allow for
now some other assumptions we make
coming back to your question of what do
we require of each partition
requires what we call span inclusions
that is the expectation of y
lies within say the row span of each of
those partitions and x tilde k
lies in the column span of x k
okay so this expectation of y align the
row span of expectation of x k is what
motivates learning a linear model
and
this condition here of your x tilde k
lying in the column spanner expectation
of x k is what we call some notion of
causal transportability that's really
what allows you to transfer your model
from a model from
from data that's learned in these
columns to this column
the other assumption you require because
you're trying to recover the mean m
is that there's enough separation of
signal and noise
so if you look at the
smaller singular value of expectation of
x one say
that that singular value is a lot larger
than the maximum singular value of the
of the noise matrix
okay one we're thinking about is that if
you have so your signals here are the
first few singular values the noise is
going to be spectrally diffused we know
that by random matrix theory and what
pcr is doing is exactly is finding that
low rank approximation so it's denoising
the system in that in that sense and
that's really what motivates using pcr
in this setting with with noisy
covariates
the fourth assumption we make
is about the observation pattern so what
we require is that this x is large
enough
we'll do meaning for learning in
particular suppose it's of size k cubed
by k square the k cubed rows and k
square columns
then x1 by xk should be divided as such
so you have k of them each of them size
k square by k square
and so given those four assumptions
these are the type of theoretical
results we can show we can show for
every pair i j that satisfies those
assumptions you have this kind of result
this entrywise result which is that m
hat i j and this mij scales as follows
here r is the rank of the matrix m
and k is the number of synthetic
neighbors right so we divided our data
up into k blocks each of size k squared
by k square
k here is that parameter here okay so it
scales as r 3 over 2 over square root k
and i note that
state in the m chord case where you
sample each thing with some probability
p such matrices those big matrices x
that have size k q by k square will
exist with high probability
okay and the exact dependence of yes
about that
so you can show it's it's it's so for
let's say
your
probability of observing something is
delta
and you can make you can show that with
that with high probability this will
scale as 1 over delta to the 12.
so you can prove so the rate
so what you need uh the thing is you
don't need just one big three you could
have many of them all over the place
right so it's not just about finding one
large enough because they can exist
everywhere the fact that there's one x
that i'm dividing into many sub matrices
is just one instance that is big enough
but all you need is like these k square
by case by things all over the place
and if you appropriately normalize your
estimate so m hat minus m hat minus m
you normalize it by square root k
given by a normalized by the right
variance proxy
then you show that you can show that
this goes to a standard normal which is
what allows you to produce confidence
intervals for your estimate
so you're saying that
when you write that
m is independent of a
you so it's sort of thinking about a
single entry like m i j and y
n can be opportunity
but they're independent given the u and
v aren't they when these people do you
be transposed
i see
so
okay that should that just holds true by
the assumption that they're equal that m
is decomposing yeah another way of
incorporating it is that you're
missing this pattern is a function only
the lower eye component
and that's the part you're recovering
the remaining part we model is epsilon
and so it's an expectation over the
epsilon
but the missing is that it can't be a
function of that excellent
so when does that break exactly like i'm
trying to think of the sort of extreme
example where this entry the probability
of observing this entry is exactly
related to its actual underlying value
that you don't know so like the
self-censoring kind of assumption
and so you're ruling that out by
forcing the the decomposition part
so i'm saying that let's say so an entry
is y i j that is equal to a lowering
component for solids so give me the
output function of the lower right
component
but not the noise so for example if
someone it's an adversary gets to see
the the outcomes noisy outcomes and
based on that decides which entries you
see not see that would not be allowed
with this style model but if the
atmosphere only gets no expectation
what's happening and the expectation is
the lowering
that's loud
so they can't they can't rule out like
every time the the matrix entry is
bigger than five i'll hide it so that'll
be ruled out by what you just said yeah
but if the expected value is greater
than five and i showed based on that
that's okay
another
thing that we're thinking about is what
is the most sample
efficient pattern for the data we looked
at and looked like this l
so
with this kind of l structure you can
recover all m times n entries at rate
one over square root k and most m times
k square plus n times k cubed entries
in particular there's no
m and n do not show up as a product but
as in an additive way which is what you
can best you can hope for
so some interesting things to think
about is that maybe this has some
implications for say experimental design
you can think about your problem of
experiment design through a matrix um
and it's given the fact that
problems in contextual bandwidth can be
thought of as a matrix
maybe there's some interesting
implications for say inference versus
regret balance in contextual bandits
and i'll just end with talking very
quickly about um
variance estimation so to produce those
confidence intervals you need to be able
to estimate the the variance of the
noise the sigma square i j is equal to
expectation of epsilon square i j
right and generally can't recover it but
given this this view of matrix
completion what's one way of thinking
about it let's say well let's assume
that this matrix of the noise is also
lorac let's see only to make the
assumption then what happens
okay so observe this that expectation of
y square i j so coordinate y squaring
what is the expectation of that is given
by m square i j plus sigma square i j
okay so now let's suppose that the
the rank of this
matrix okay is it is s
what is its rank its rank is going to be
bounded by the rank of
of m squared
which we assume to be low rank and given
that we assume that sigma is lower rank
then s also has to be lower
right
so if m is low rank the variance is a
low rank then this matrix the coordinate
y square is also low rank
and that's what we're going to explain
oh so this is the algorithm so first you
apply
you do it on the matrix m that you
observe sorry the matrix white tilde
that you observe you apply synthetic
nearest neighbors on that to get mri j
when you do it on the y squaring you
apply synthetic numerators on that
what's the estimate you get from that
you get m square i j plus sigma square i
j you get a you get an estimate for that
entire thing
and then you simply take the estimate
you get from the second one minus the
estimate you get from the first one
squared that's it given this you can
estimate heteroskedastic variances
and so what kind of guarantee can you
provide suppose the error for the the
first step is given by delta one and the
error for the second synthetic nearest
neighbor is given by delta two then your
coordinate wise entry recovery of the
variance of sigma squared j minus sigma
hat i j
is bounded by the max of
delta one delta one squared plus delta
two okay so that's it now you can do
coordinate wise recovery
so one interesting use case of this say
you have no missing data you have a
matrix of of uh of normals okay with the
mean and a variance and say the means
are are low rank and the variance is the
lower and they just give you one
observation from a from a normal
and they have a matrix given synthetic
nearest name is i can recover the mean
and the variance of those normals given
just one sample of it
okay so now let me end very quickly
so
i think there's a lot to be done between
these two fields of causal inference and
matrix completion for those of us in
causal infants we say well causal
influence is a missing data problem from
those of us in matrix completion we say
matrix completion is a missing data
problem and i think there's one-to-one
mappings between many core ideas and one
or the other
so
for example the goal of causal inference
is to estimate potential outcomes that
really amounts to imputing missing
entries in your
in your matrix and different kinds of
observational experimental studies that
really amounts to induces different
[ __ ] patterns in your given
matrix
this notion of confounding and causal
influence can be thought of as having
missing not random data
and the types of of causal esterman for
example the average treatment effect
individual treatment effect etc that
really is amounts to recovery in
different kinds of norms so you can
think of maybe the frobenius gnome is
something related to like the average
treatment effect and the infinity norm
is somewhat related to the individual
treatment effect et cetera you can do
those mappings
with that i'd like to end thank you very
much
i guess like a kind of related question
so
the
the missing data identification
literature usually focuses on recovering
like the joint distribution of the
things that you think are observed with
missingness
and your result is specifically about
like this estimation error
which is usually kind of
implied by but not the same as that
recovering the joint distribution so can
you comment on that relationship but
it's a good point i don't know the
answer that so sense what we're doing is
recovering the marginal distributions
regeneration but if you wonder a
recovery on say the joint distribution
of all the missingness values
that's that's a good question
okay
you